I'M CALLING THE HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER AS A SUBCOMMITTEE --
WE WILL HAVE THE SECRETARY
SELFISH OR A ROLE WHEN WE BEARD
OF A QUORUM --
WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS --
LINE MEASURES ON FILE THAT I TO
HAVE BEEN PULLED AND THREE ARE
ON CONSENT THE CONSENT ITEMS ARE
AS FOLLOWS ITEM NUMBER ONE HR.
THIRTY BY --
THIS QUIRK SILVA ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB --
NINE ONE SIX THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OMNIBUS BILL
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN I ASKED YOU
ARE NINETEEN BY MISTER WILK.
THE MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN
PULLED OUR ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP
EIGHT NINE TWO AND ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SP.
ELEVEN OH FOR MISTER ROTH AT
LEAST SIX BILLS TO BE HEARD.
WE'LL TAKE TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON EACH
MEASURE THAT'S TO INTO.
I EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
AGAIN IT'S ONLY TWO MINUTES NO
LONGER THAN THAT ALL OTHERS MAY
LINE UP AND STATE THEIR AYE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL'S.
WITH THAT I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE
AN AUTHOR MY SENATOR HILL IS
PRESENT.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY A
CENTER HELL IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING --
FILE ITEM.
NINE S. BICU ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
[inaudible]
COOL [inaudible]
EDUCATION.
OUR PARENT OR GUARDIAN. TO COME
ON CAMPUS TO ADMINISTER MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO THEM IN NON SMOKING
AND NON BABY INFORMED.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS NEED TO
TAKE A DOSE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
AT REGULAR INTERVALS.
WHICH OFTEN INCLUDES DURING
SCHOOL HOURS.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW ANY
FORM OF CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS THE STUDENTS MUST BE
PICKED UP BY THEIR PARENTS.
AND TAKEN OFF CAMPUS IN ORDER TO
TAKE THEIR MEDICINE.
IN FACT I BELIEVE IT'S ONE
THOUSAND FEET AWAY FROM CAMPUS.
THIS IS VERY DISRUPTIVE TO THEIR
LEARNING S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN WILL ALLOW THE GOVERNING
BOARD OF A K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOL DISTRICT COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION OR A CHARTER SCHOOL TO
CHOOSE WHETHER TO ADOPT THIS
POLICY.
IT IS NOT A STATE MANDATE.
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES THAT OPT
IN CAN OPT OUT FOR ANY REASON.
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PUT AT RISK AS A RESULT OF THIS
POLICY IS BETWEEN.
ONE ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN REQUIRES
A STUDENT TO BE QUALIFIED.
MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENT WITH A
DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION
TYPICALLY THE MEDICINE IS THAT
BEEN ADMINISTERED AS OIL
CAPSULES TEACHERS LIQUIDS OR
TOPICAL CREAMS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT A
PARENT MUST GIVE THE SCHOOL A
COPY OF THEIR CHILD'S MEDICAL
CANNABIS RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP
ON FILE.
SIGN IN WHEN THEY COME ON CAMPUS
TO ADMINISTER THE MEDICINE NOT
DISRUPT THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT.
TAKE ALL CANNABIS FROM SCHOOL
GROUNDS AFTER ADMINISTRATION
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO
LEGALLY ADMINISTER ANY
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUG.
INCLUDING OPIOIDS THAT A CHILD
HAS BEEN PRESCRIBED.
BUT THERE ARE NO MEDICAL
CONDITIONS PHARMACEUTICALS CAN'T
FIX.
AND THEY OFTEN HAVE DEBILITATING
SIDE EFFECTS MEDICAL CANNABIS
HELPS FILL SOME OF THESE GAPS
AND LESS IN THESE CHALLENGING
SIDE EFFECTS.
PARENTS ACROSS THE NATION HAVE
HAD SUCCESS TREATING THEIR
CHILDREN WITH MEDICAL CANNABIS
WHEN NO PHARMACEUTICAL WOULD
WORK.
WASHINGTON COLORADO FLORIDA
MAINE AND NEW JERSEY HAVE ALL
PASSED LEGISLATION ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO USE MEDICAL CANNABIS
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND I
HAVE A WISH CONSERVE OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED.
MY NAME IS GREG GARCIA AND I AM
HERE TO SPLIT THE SUPPORT JUDGE
SHOWS ACT SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN MY SON IS
STILL RUNNING JO JO HUMANISTS HE
HAS USED CANNABIS IN A FOUR
MONTHS OF TEACHERS CPBL TEACH
THE FOR THE PAST FOUR YEARS.
HE HAS BEEN PLAGUED WITH
EPILEPSY SINCE THE AGE OF THREE
MONTHS OLD.
HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH LENNOX
CUSTO SYNDROME IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THIS KINDA EPILEPSY IS
VERY VERY HARD TO CONTROL.
HE WAS MEDICATED WITH VERY HIGH
DOSES OF PHARMACEUTICALS AND
ALSO FIT IT WITH THE VAGUS NERVE
STIMULATOR.
ALL WITH NO SUCCESS.
I WAS WATCHING MY SON DIE RIGHT
BEFORE MY EYES.
I NEW THERE HAD TO BE A BETTER
WAY.
I BEGAN RESEARCHING CANNABIS AND
AFFECTS OF IT TO TREAT EPILEPSY.
AND CHOSE TO TRY IT AS OUR LAST
RESORT.
IT SEEMED VERY HOPEFUL FROM THE
VERY START.
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTEEN WAS THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE TRIED.
AND DAY BY DAY I SEEN HIM EMERGE
FROM IS MEDICAID IT'S THE IN
FIGHTING DJING AGAIN.
CAESARS WERE DECREASED
IMMEDIATELY.
AYE SUPPORT THIS BILL TO TO THE
FACT THAT JOE JOE NEEDS A DOSE
AT SCHOOL EVERY DAY AT TWELVE PM.
I FEEL CANNABIS SHOULD BE
TREATED AS EVERY OTHER
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ON CAMPUS
IT IS NOT FAIR.
THAT THIS MEDICINE HAS SAVED MY
SON'S LIFE AND NOT BE GIVEN THE
SAME TREATMENT.
AND ABILITY AS OTHER
PHARMACEUTICALS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS BILL
BECOMING LAW MY SON'S LIFE AND
SO MANY OTHERS DEPEND ON IT.
IN FIVE THOUSAND YEARS NO ONE
HAS DIED FROM CANNABIS USE IT IS
THE ONLY MEDICINE THAT CAN TREAT
SO MANY DIFFERENT ELEMENTS ON
SUCH A WIDE SPECTRUM.
FROM EPILEPSY TO ARTHRITIS TO
CANCER TO PARKINSON'S.
IT IS ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REGENERATE BRAIN CELLS I HAVE
SEEN THIS FIRSTHAND WITH MY
CHILD.
I ASK YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART TO GIVE A YES VOTE TODAY
AND BE THE VOICE OF MY SON AND
SO MANY OTHERS THAT NEED.
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMPASSION.
THANK YOU.
UP TO WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
PEOPLE'S COLOR.
BUT DON UP HERE.
BUT HERE KILEY.
KILEY HERE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
WEBER HERE [inaudible]
QUORUM.
WE DO IT AN ACCORD HAS BEEN A
SALAS THANK YOU OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ERICA
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
AYE WE DO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
WE SEE THIS AS WELL A LOCAL
DECISION.
AND ABILITY FOR LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION TO SEE IF
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE ACTION FOR
THEM AND THEIR CHILDREN.
IT HAS BEEN SHOWN THAT.
THIS MEDICATION FOR LACK OF A
DIFFERENT WORD --
DOES HELP TO PROVIDE A NUMBER OF
CHILDREN WITH THE APPROPRIATE
EDUCATION WITHOUT FEELING AS IF
THEY'RE ON OPIOIDS AND OUT OF
TOUCH WITH SOCIETY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS DOES BECOME
A LOCAL ISSUE AND WE WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THINKING.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CRISTINA
MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA ONE OF
THE LARGEST VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CANNABIS OPERATIONS
IN THE STATE AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU.
UP OTHERS IN OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY NO FURTHER OPPOSITION --
THANK YOU ARE YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE --
RETURN.
I COMMITTEE CHAIRED I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL THANK YOU
GOD FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY I I I JUST HAD A QUESTION.
ARM FOR CONTACTS AND HOW OFTEN
ARE THESE CONVERSATIONS NOW
TAKING PLACE.
IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS HOW MANY
STUDENTS FIND THEMSELVES WITH
THE NEED TO HAVE ACCESS --
TO MEDICATION JUST BECAUSE IT.
WHEN THE BILL CAME TO ME I
HADN'T BEEN AWARE THAT WE WERE
FORCING STUDENTS --
ACCESS MEDICATION OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL OR MAYBE IN WAYS THAT
WOULD MAKE THEM UNSAFE.
AND I ONE HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
HOW SCHOOLS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT --
OUR STUDENTS IN HOW COMMON ARE
THESE NEEDS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
SENSE OF THAT OR ANY OF THE
WITNESSES HAVE ANY SENSE OF THAT.
ON HOW OFFICE COMES UP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN I I DON'T
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF MORE THAN JUST
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
BUT I BELIEVE OBVIOUSLY IF WITH
THE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
EMBRACED THIS AND I THINK IN
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT.
UP AROUND THE IMPACT TO DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT THERE ARE
OTHERS BUT I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
SPECIFIC CASES.
BUT BEING OUR CATS --
CIRCLE THERE ARE A LOT OF
CHILDREN THAT HAVE NEEDS THAT
NEED TO TAKE MEDICATION AT
SCHOOL WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
IS MOST PARENTS ARE TRYING TO
SCHEDULE IT AROUND SCHOOL BUT
IT'S NOT WORKING THEY'RE NOT
ACHIEVING THE CONTROL THAT THEY
NEED.
BECAUSE ARE WITHHOLDING
MEDICATION TIMES.
SO THERE IS A GREATER NEED AND
IF THEY'RE SAFE ACCESS I BELIEVE
MORE PARENTS AND FAMILIES WILL
BE MORE WILLING TO COME FORWARD.
IMAGINE IF THIS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE A LOT A TRADING IN
SUPPORT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER POLICIES
GET CREATED.
ARE CONSISTENT DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT TO NOT A LOT OF OF
FOLKS CSPA HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
HOW TO DO THAT I MEAN I KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE I WE HAVE EXAMPLE DOCTOR
WEBER HAS INTRODUCED A BILL --
THAT HELPS OUR STUDENTS TO BE
SAFE -- AND
MAKE HEALTHY CHOICES IN SCHOOL
AND THEIR OTHER SIMILAR BILLS
WHERE THERE'S A STATE MANDATE
BUT HOW IT GETS RULED OUT AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL SOME DISTRICTS DO
WELL AND OTHERS.
NOT SO WELL AND SO I'M
INTERESTED WORK --
TO IMPLEMENT THIS INSTANTLY EVEN
IF IT LOOKS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY SEE --
STARTED THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITHIN OUR OWN ORGANIZATION OF
WHAT THIS POTENTIALLY LOOKS LIKE
WITH LEGAL COUNSEL WITH OTHERS --
WE WILL IF THIS DOES BECOME LAW
WE WILL PUT TOGETHER A SET OF
DRAFT POLICIES WHICH IS THEN
SENT OUT EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THIS WITHIN THE STATE.
MOST DISTRICTS MIGHT MAKE A WORD
CHANGER TO BUT FOR THE MOST PART
A LOT OF THEM TO ADOPT WITH THE
DRAFT POLICY IS.
SO THERE WOULD HOPEFULLY PROVIDE
SOME CONSISTENCY I WILL ALSO
RELATE THIS CONVERSATION BACK TO
OUR POLICY DEVELOPMENT STAFF.
SAID THERE WHERE OF TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE USE.
IF KNOW THAT'S COMMON LANGUAGE
THAT EVERYBODY CAN UNDERSTAND.
AND THAT IT GETS TO THE ISSUE OF
MAKING SURE THE KIDS ARE SAFE --
AND THAT PARENTS HAVE ACCESS BUT
THAT THE SCHOOL SITE IS ALSO.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU IF I
COULD POINT OUT MISTER CHAIR IS
THAT THIS IS NOT A MANDATE SO
THIS THE GRAPHICS THAT SHOW SO
CHOOSE YOUR DESIRE TO DO IT CAN
DO IT IN THOSE.
MAY FIND IT AWKWARD OR
UNCOMFORTABLE ONE LEFT RIGHT AND
AND ALSO TO MISTER TERENCE
QUESTION ABOUT YOU HOW AND HOW
OFTEN AS IS HAPPENING --
I JUST MAKE TWO POINTS OF MY
I'VE BEEN READING ABOUT THIS FOR
NUMBER YEAR SOME SHIRTS
HAPPENING TO OTHERS HERE.
AND IN OUR STATE POSSIBLE IN
FORWARD I'M FAMILIAR WITH THE
DRUG THAT'S COMING OUT IN THE
OVER THE NEXT YEAR THAT SPEAKS
TO MAYBE EVEN THIS EXACT
SITUATION.
THAT'S CANNABINOID BASED AS I
UNDERSTAND IT SO IT'S IT'S GOING
BACK BUT IT'S ALSO GOING FORWARD.
WHEN THINGS HAVE MEDICINAL VALUE
WE WE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THEM?
SO WITH THAT ID FOR THE COMMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE DO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION I'M OF THE BILL.
BUT THE MOVE IS SECONDED YOU
WISH TO CLOSE REFRESH MY BUT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS -- DO
PASSED YOU JUST YOUR AVERAGE
THIS YEAR.
O'DONNELL AYE AYE.
O'DONNELL I KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
STEINORTH.
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE [inaudible] THREE
LITTLE.
THE WORLD THE BILL'S THREE VOTES
IS ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HE'S WAY MORE THANK YOU
THEIR OTHER MAILERS LIKELY
CHRISTIAN --
I SEE MISTER WORK OUT THERE --
FILE ITEM NUMBER BOTH BILL
NUMBER [inaudible]
I KNOW.
I DON'T I CAN'T RESIST.
IT'S S. B. TEN THIRTY SIX FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
IS S. B. TEN THIRTY SIX WHICH
WILL CLARIFY PROCEDURES FOR THE
RELEASE OF A STUDENT'S DIRECTORY
INFORMATION AND SCHOOL BOARD.
CHARTER SCHOOL BOARD AND COUNTY
BOARD --
BOARDS OF EDUCATION MEETING
MINUTES I AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN S. STAFF FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK IT WILL BE TAKING
ALL THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
THAT WERE SUBMITTED TO US.
CURRENTLY FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS FOR
THE RELEASE OF STUDENTS
DIRECTORS INFORMATION.
IN THE PUBLIC --
UNDER MOST CIRCUMSTANCES
TYPICALLY CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE CHOSEN. TO
NOT RELEASE THIS INFORMATION BUT
THERE HAVE BEEN INSTANCES WHERE
INFORMATION IS BEEN RELEASED TO
THE DETRIMENT OF THE STUDENT AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS RELEASE OF INFORMATION HAS
BEEN HAS LED TO TROUBLING ISSUES
AT OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES
PRIMARILY THE RELEASE OF
INFORMATION OR POTENTIAL THERE
OF CAN HAVE THE EFFECT OF
SUPPRESSING PURCHASE A PITY
PATIENT AND DISSENT. FOR
INSTANCE ON CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES
BEFORE THE BOARD SOME STUDENTS
PARENTS GUARDIANS ARE RELATIVES
FEEL THAT.
THE RELEASE OF THEIR HOME
ADDRESS PRESENTS POTENTIAL FOR
HARM OR OTHER HARASSMENT BASED
UPON THEIR TESTIMONY DURING THE
MEETING.
I THIS IS BROUGHT TO BE FROM A
FROM A CONSTITUENT AFRICAN
AMERICAN GRANDMOTHER WHO WHILE
READING A BOOK THIS ACTUALLY
PROVE BY THAT PART IN EDUCATION
FIFTH GRADE BOOK.
FOUND IT OFFENSIVE WENT TO THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING VERY
CONTENTIOUS --
A SITUATION.
AND I FELT VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
THE BOARD RICH WOULD DIRECT IT
REJECTED HER APPEAL.
THEY WENT BACK THE NEXT BOARD
MAYBE SEE WHAT HAPPENED AND
THEY'RE REALLY THROUGH THE
MINUTES AND HER NAME IN A IN A
DRESS AND EVERYTHING IS IN THERE
AND I THINK.
DURING THESE TIMES I I I DON'T I
JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY.
SO SUIT SO SITUATIONS LIKE THIS
HAVE LED TO THE PERCEPTION THAT
THE RELEASE OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION MAY.
BE EMPLOYED IN A MANNER LEADING
TO INTIMIDATION IN RESPONSE AND
FAVORABLE TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS.
SCHOOL COMMUNITY SO THIS.
S. B. TEN THIRTY SIX WILL HELP
PREVENT THAT.
AND AGAIN I WOULD ASK YOU FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO OTHER SINCE WERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION ANY CONSUMMATED
COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
YOU MAYOR CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AGAIN THE MOTION IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
AGAIN YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AYE YES PLEASE CALL THE ROOM ALL
IT WOULD DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
I'D IRATE CLUB THAT'S ALL GOOD
AND I WAS CALDERON.
O'DONNELL AYE AYE FOR DONNELL
AYE KILEY KILEY I KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH THURMOND
THURMOND AYE WEBER WEBER AYE
[inaudible]
VOTE.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT IS
HOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE OTHER AUTHORS HERE
CAN WE GET THE OTHERS CALL HIM A
FEW MINUTES OTHERWISE.
WHEN I WAIT ALL DAY SO?
I HAVE A SENATOR JACKSON
[inaudible]
I HAVE [inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE --
IN THAT I HAVE BEEN.
LISTENING.
PORTANTINO CENTER PORTANTINO.
OKAY ARM I WHEN WE GOING TO GET
THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS AS
FOLLOWS -- I
AM RIVER ONE HR.
THIRTY BY MISS QUIRK SILVA THE
MOTION IS A TO BE ADOPTED.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB EIGHT ONE
SIX AUTHOR IS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THAT'S TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS I AND
NUMBER ELEVEN SG ARE.
NINETEEN BY CENTER WILL OF OF
THE MOTION IS.
A TO BE ADOPTED DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
SO MOVED AND SECONDED BY MISTER
THURMAN --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL I O'DONNELL AYE KILEY
KIND THE KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER WEBER AYE.
YEAH THAT IS OUT OKAY WILL NEXT
WE'LL HEAR --
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO CENTER
PORTANTINO SP.
I DON'T KNOW.
WHICH ONE YOU WANT TO DO FIRST.
S. B. [inaudible]
THREE FIFTY FOUR OKAY.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY TAKING THE
COMMITTEE --
STAFF OVER THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY.
WITH MY OFFICE OVER THE PAST
YEAR ON THIS.
IMPORTANT ISSUE TODAY I'M
PRESENTING S. B. THREE FIVE FOUR
WHICH REQUIRES A LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY. TO PROVIDE A STUDENT.
PARENTS WITH A COPY OF COMPLETE
BY THE WAY I RAN HERE.
AND I'M.
AND I'M OLD AND FAT NOW TO SHAPE
SO.
THIS COULD BE A LOT BETTER FOR
THE RECORD I'M OLD AND FAT
MATTER SHAPE NOW HOW LONG DO THE
CPR AND YOU SO JUST TO AND I
DON'T WANT YOU TO DO CPR ON ME.
EITHER -- SO
DERISIVE INSTANT PARENTS WITH A
COPY OF A COMPLETED INDIVIDUAL
EDUCATION PLAN. FOR THE EIGHT
MOST COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGES
IN THAT DISTRICT WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OF BEING REQUESTED.
AS WELL AS REQUIRE THE I EP
TRANSLATOR THE BILL LOS REQUIRES
TO THE TO REVISE ITS NOTICE OF
PROCEDURAL SAFEGUARDS IN ORDER
TO INFORM PARENTS.
OF THEIR RIGHT TO REQUEST THE
TRANSLATION DOCUMENTS EXISTING
LAW REQUIRES ELEAZAR TO TAKE ANY
ACTION NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
A PARENT OR GUARDIAN UNDERSTANDS
THE PROCEEDINGS IN A MEETING
INCLUDING ARRANGING FOR AN
INTERPRETER. FOR PARENTS WITH
DEAFNESS OR WHOSE NATIVE
LANGUAGE IS A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH ADDITIONALLY
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT SET.
TIMELINE FOR IEP DOCUMENTS TO BE
TRANSLATED.
THE IP PROCESS CAN BE VERY
OVERWHELMING INTIMIDATING FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THE PROCESS OR THE TERMINOLOGY
ESPECIALLY IF THAT PERSON'S
PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS NOT ENGLISH.
OF THE LACK OF HAVING A TIMELY
AND ACCURATE TRANSLATE IP.
DOES A GREAT DISSERVICE TO BOTH
THE PARENTS AND THE STUDENTS AND
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS FOR
PARENTS HAVE A MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION.
IN THE IEP PROCESS WHICH IS
REQUIRED BY CURRENT WHICH IS
REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW AND ALSO
TO PROVIDE PARENTS WITH
TRANSLATED COPY SO.
I LIKED INTRODUCED.
EVELYN IS HERE FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS AND CHRISTOPHER UP FROM
THE COALITION OF HUMAN --
RIGHT SO TO SPEAK ON THE MERITS
OF THREE OR FOUR EVELYN I'M
HOUSING DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL OVER PLEASE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THE ISSUES WITH
THE BILL.
ARMED THE IP IS A LEGAL DOCUMENT
THAT SETS OUT LEGAL RIGHTS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
PARENTS NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE DOCUMENT SAYS WHEN THEY
AGREE TO THOSE SERVICES.
SO REALLY PLEASED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A THIRTY DAY TIMELINE
AND A QUALIFIED TRANSLATOR
TRANSLATE THAT DOCUMENTS OF
PARENTS CAN --
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS
MEANINGFULLY IN A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR BECAUSE KIDS GET THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED SO WITH
THAT.
WERE WERE PLEASED WE REACHED FOR
RESOLUTION AND AND HAPPY TO SEE
THE BILL MOVING SO.
CHRIS RESPONSE IS WHAT YOU'RE
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS SIDE STRONG
SUPPORT PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR
OF THE BILL --
IT'S REALLY CRUCIAL THAT MANY OF
OUR FAMILIES --
WHO HAVE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE BEEN
GIVEN IP'S ARE SOMETIMES AND
WILL TRANSLATE ARE NO LONGER GET
THOSE DOCUMENTS AND WILL
TRANSLATE TO AND TO ENSURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THE LEGAL
DOCUMENT AT THE FRONT?
IN FRONT OF THEM I'LL FOR THEIR
CHILDREN SO WE'RE GLAD THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO WORK OUT THE
ISSUES AND ALSO THAT THE BILL'S
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD.
EYES REALLY A CIVIL JUSTICE
MATTER FOR OUR FOLKS AND
THINKING WE ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON
RAPIDLY HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AS A
FORMER TEACHER HAVING SAT IN A
NUMBER OF BY A P. MEETINGS IT'S
CRITICAL THAT PARENTS UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S IN THE DOCUMENT --
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL WE WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
TERESA ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ARKHAM UCP CALIFORNIA
COOPERATION AND SUPPORT.
MARCH EXCUSE ME MAR THIS AREA
GOES IDEAS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ANGELIQUE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND STRONG SUPPORTER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
A SENIOR OPPOSITION COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MR THERE.
AIMS TO CHARING THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL AND I THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR AND I THINK
YOU STATED ALL THE REASONS BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
MY DISTRICT FOR WHOM.
ENGLISH IS NOT THEIR FIRST
LANGUAGE AND MORE THAN FORTY
THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS TO OUR
SERVER BY SPECIAL EDUCATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
WELL BILL SECOND THINK REMOVED
AND SECONDED BY MISTER THURMAN --
PLEASE CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR
OF THIS WAS SENT TO YOUR BILL
BECAUSE IT NEEDED THE CARE.
AND FOCUS I WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF AND MY STAFF.
OF FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY TO GET
IT TO THE POINT WHERE.
ALL THE ADVOCATES ARE ONBOARD
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE KIND
WORDS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THE MOTIONS YOU PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL O'DONNELL AYE AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WEBER
WEBER AYE.
IT IS FIVE VOTED IS OUT THANK
YOU.
NEXT ALTERNATE SENATOR JACKSON'S
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AND ALONE.
OPIATES IN THEM.
NIGHT.
SEVEN TWO S. B. A FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX S. B. [inaudible]
NINE SEVEN TWO ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HERE --
THANK YOU --
AGAIN WHICH TO CHAD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF ON S. B. --
NINE SEVEN TWO WHICH REQUIRE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS INCLUDING ALL
CHARTER AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT
SERVE STUDENTS --
BETWEEN SEVEN TWELVE IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND ALSO THROUGH COLLEGE.
PRINT STUDENT ON THEIR STUDENT
ID CARD A SUICIDE PREVENTION --
NUMBER OR TEXT --
SADLY I CAN SAY I JUST IT'S
BREAKING MY HEART BUT THERE IS A
HIGH SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT THAT
HAS HAD THREE SUICIDES THIS YEAR --
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS
TOUCHED FAMILY --
SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO. TO MAKE
THIS INFORMATION READILY
AVAILABLE TO OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR CHILDREN IS NEEDED AND SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I DON'T.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ERICA HOSPITAL BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THINKING.
LYDIA WARREN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES AND THE CALIFORNIA
DIVISION OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS BOTH IN SUPPORT.
JEFF FLOCK OF REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS ON THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
OVER THE YEARS WITH THIS SUMMER
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LARA WASCO A BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HALF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
MELISSA AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN SPORT.
THANK YOU I ANY OPPOSITION.
A SCENE OPPOSITION ANY
CONSUMMATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OTHERS HAVE HAD THAT PARTICULAR
ARTIST HOUSE MOTION OKAY YOU MAY
CLOSE JUST THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
FOR THE MOTION IS ON TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I LITTLE HAS EXPOSED SO IT
IS OUT OKAY IT'S GOING TO
APPROACH THAT TO THE FLOOR.
SORRY IT'S GOING TO APPROACH IS
A KEY FISCAL.
YEAH APPARENTLY WAS REQUESTED BY
APPROPRIATIONS OF HOPE.
THERE YOU GO VERY OFTEN OUR
WORLD [inaudible]
I'M SMILING --
NEXT UP UNDER FIVE US SENATOR
JACKSON.
THAT'S S. B..
NINE FOUR SEVEN FILE UNDER.
FIVE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALL START SMILING
IS SWELLED HOPE I MAYBE TO KEEP
A GRIN AND THAT YOU ARE.
OF SUPPORTIVE OF IT S. B..
NINE FORTY SEVEN THIS IS
LEGISLATION TO CREATE A PROCESS
FOR PARENTS STUDENTS EDUCATORS
AND OTHER EDUCATIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON TOOLS AND BEST
PRACTICES TO TEACH DIGITAL
CITIZENSHIP.
MEDIA LITERACY AND THE SAFE USE
OF TECHNOLOGY.
I AM ACCEPTING HIS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WHICH I BELIEVE ARE --
BOTH CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL IN
NATURE.
SO THIS IS A WORLD WHERE WHEN I
FIRST -- THE
CAME TO THIS --
BODY BACK LITTLE WHILE AGO.
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT DIGITAL
CITIZENSHIP MEDIA LITERACY OR
THE SAFE USE OF TECHNOLOGY WOULD
ENTAIL.
WE KNOW TODAY THOUGH THE
TEENAGERS SPANNED AB AN AVERAGE
OF FIFTY HOURS A WEEK ONLINE.
FIFTY HOURS A WEEK AND MY
PARENTS USED TO COMPLAIN WHEN
I'D SPEND FIVE HOURS A WEEK ON
THE PHONE.
BUT IT'S A DIFFERENT WORLD.
THE NUMBER FOR TWEENS IS EVEN
HIGHER.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO
COMPREHENSIVE STANDARDS FOR
TEACHING STUDENTS ABOUT THE MORE
CRITICAL ASPECTS OF DIGITAL
CITIZENSHIP THINGS LIKE.
SEXTING CYBERBULLYING PRIVACY
AND FAKE NEWS.
EDUCATORS ARE FACED WITH THE
OFTEN OVERWHELMING CHALLENGES
PRESENTED BY TECHNOLOGY USAGE BY
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS TO
STRUGGLE TO MAKE SENSE.
OF AN EVER CHANGING DIGITAL
LANDSCAPE.
S. B. NINE FORTY SEVEN WOULD
ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY PANEL
COMPRISED OF EDUCATION EXPERTS
WORKING IN TANDEM WITH THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IS OFFICE. TO
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES AND
STRATEGIES THAT SUPPORT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS INCLUDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR EDUCATORS AND
ADMINISTRATORS HOW DO WE DO WITH
THESE VERY CRITICAL ISSUES.
SENATOR PORTANTINO TALKED ABOUT
SUICIDE WE KNOW THAT THEIR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO COMMIT SUICIDE TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE BULLYING THAT
GOES ON ON THE INTERNET.
OFTENTIMES OTHER STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS ACTIVITY
DON'T HAVE ANY NOTION THAT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS PUSHING A YOUNG
PERSON OVER THE EDGE.
WE NEED TO DO BETTER TODAY THIS
IS A VERY DIFFERENT WORLD THAN
THE WORLD THAT I GREW UP IN IN
THE PERHAPS MANY OF YOU ALSO
GREW UP IN AND WE NEED TO COME.
TO THE POINT WHERE WE ARE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES USING
THE BEST PRACTICES ALLOWING OUR
TEACHERS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE HEALTH WELL
BEING EDUCATION.
AND TRAINING OF OUR YOUTH TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THOSE TOOLS TO
ASSIST SO THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE
THE BENEFITS OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WILL MINIMIZE THEIR
ADVERSE IMPACTS ON OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
AND WITH THAT --
THIS MEASURE IS SUPPORTED BY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
EDUCATORS PARENTS JOURNALISTS
AND STUDENTS AND WITH ME TODAY
IN SUPPORT THIS DANIEL CANDLE
KISER OF COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION.
AND BETH ORTON WITH THE CENTER
FOR MEDIA LITERACY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM DANIEL
COUNTER KAISER WITH COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
WE ARE THE LEGISLATIVE ARM OF
COMMON SENSE MEDIA WE EMPOWER
PARENTS TEACHERS AND POLICY
MAKERS BY PROVIDING THE TOOLS TO
HELP.
FAMILIES AND KIDS HARNESS THE
POWER OF MEDIA AND TECHNOLOGY AS
A POSITIVE FORCE IN KIDS LIVES.
AS WE NINE FOUR SEVEN ADDRESSES
THE NEW REALITY THAT IT IS NO
LONGER ENOUGH TO TEACH OUR
CHILDREN TO BE GOOD CITIZENS IN
THE REAL WORLD.
WE MUST TEACH THEM TO BE GOOD
SMART CAUTIOUS AN ETHICAL
DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP CITIZENS AS
WELL.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES
AND IT ALSO ADDRESSES THE
INCREDIBLE POTENTIAL FOR
LEARNING THEIR IMPROVING OUR
STUDENTS MEDIA LITERACY.
AS OUR KIDS INCREASINGLY GO AND
MARK GO ONLINE TO PULL STUDY AND
ENTERTAIN THEMSELVES THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD EMPOWER
EDUCATORS. TO EQUIP STUDENTS
WITH THE CRITICAL THINKING
SKILLS NECESSARY TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY SEE IN
READ ONLINE.
QUESTIONS THAT COULD LEAD TO
IMPROVED MEDIA LITERACY AS WELL.
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IS
EXCITED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR
LEARNING THAT THE SPOKEN BRING
TO ALL CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AND
WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO I'M BETH ORTON FROM THE
CENTER FOR MEDIA LITERACY.
CARE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE FOUR SEVEN THE CENTER FOR
MEDIA LITERACY WAS FOUNDED IN
LOS ANGELES IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE THAT'S ABOUT THREE DECADES
EVEN MORE ADMINISTRATIONS AGO.
THE MEDIA LITERACY FIELD HAS
BEEN GROWING AND EVOLVING FOR
YEARS.
AND WE HAVE FINALLY REACHED A
CRITICAL MOMENT IN TIME.
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS ANALYZE
AND EVALUATE INFORMATION IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S WORLD.
UNDERSTANDING THE PROPHET POWER
DYNAMICS OF THE MEDIA
ENVIRONMENT IS COMPLICATED AND
REQUIRE STRONG CRITICAL THINKING
SKILLS.
SKILLS THAT RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE. TO BECOME
MEDIA LITERATE REQUIRES PRACTICE
AND TRAINING NOT ONLY FOR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR TEACHERS
AND LIBRARIANS.
MEDIA LITERACY LEGISLATION HAS
PASSED OR IS CURRENTLY PENDING
IN FOURTEEN STATES.
AND IS ALREADY BEING TAUGHT IN
SEVERAL COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
THIS IS AN URGENT GLOBAL ISSUE.
WE MUST DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES
RESOURCES AND A PLAN FOR
TEACHING MEDIA LITERACY AND
DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP.
IN K. TWELVE SCHOOLS.
LET'S GET CALIFORNIA ON BOARD I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
IT'S ABOUT GARCIA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANGELINA KATERI'S ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROFESSIONALS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MORE WHAT'S GOING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SENIOR OPPOSITION ANY COSMETIC
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
THEY ARE.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
BUT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE WERE LONG
OVERDUE AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR UNCLE.
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY NO [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I STEINORTH THURMOND
THURMOND AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I BOTH.
THE BILL IS OUT AS FIVE VOTES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S THANK YOU.
I NEXT WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN A SENATOR MCGUIRE.
IT'S AB FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
THIS FILE NUMBER.
TEN YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
IF ANY MISTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR I WOULD BE
HERE TODAY NET MEMBERS I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK ON THIS
BILL MISTER CHAIR --
KNOWING HOW TO FIND AND KEEP A
GOOD JOB.
AYE IS A CRITICAL SKILL I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE FOR STUDENTS
PREPARE FOR DOLE.
TO BUT AS WE ALL KNOW CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES CALIFORNIA MINERS
HAVE WORKED FOR ME.
IN ORDER TO SECURE JOB.
THESE WERE PERMITS ARE REQUIRED
REGARDLESS OF THE TIME THE YEAR
EVEN DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS OR
SCHOOL BREAKS.
IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS MAY SET
THEIR OWN POLICIES ON SCHOOL
PERMITS SOME POLICIES REQUIRE
STUDENTS DEBORAH CERTAIN GRADE
POINT AVERAGE OR ATTENDANCE RATE.
AS A RESULT STUDENTS CAN BE
UNFAIRLY DENIED PARTICIPATION IN
SUMMER WORK SUCH AS PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY DID INTENDED FOR
LOW INCOME INDOOR DISADVANTAGE
YOU'VE.
THE COW FOR TRAVEL TEN THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY OFFER US SUBSIDIZE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TRIBAL USED DURING THE SUMMER
MONTHS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL CASES WHERE STUDENTS ARE
UNABLE TO OBTAIN WORK PERMITS
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THEY FAILED TO
MEET THE GPA ATTENDANCE RECORD
GPA OR TENANTS REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEIR FOR THEIR FOR HAVE
BEEN DENIED WORK PERMITS IN
ORDER TO PARTICIPATE IN SUMMER
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED. FOR THEM.
WE MUST HELP ADVANCE STUDENTS
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO WANT TO GAIN
WORK EXPERIENCE SP FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WILL REMOVE THE
BARRIER FOR MINORS TO OBTAIN A
WORK PERMIT.
DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS BY
PROHIBITING THE DENIAL OF A WORK
PERMIT ON THE BASIS OF A
STUDENT'S GRADES.
GRADE POINT AVERAGE OR SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE IF THE STUDENT IS
APPLYING FOR A WORK PERMIT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE GOVERNOR
ADMINISTERED EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING PROGRAM SECOND BE FOR
EXAMPLE.
YOUTH CONSERVATION COURSE SOME
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUBS --
IS WELL AS YOUTH EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAMS THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IT'S S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL
HELP STUDENTS ONE IMPROVE
THEMSELVES LIFT UP THEIR
FAMILIES FOR EMPLOYMENT.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY TWO AMAZING
WOMEN THAT LAURIE LEWIS
EDUCATION DIRECTOR FOR THE CALF
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL TEN A
PARTNERSHIP IN OF COURSE JUST
BARCELO IN TWENTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS PART LOW FOR ALL OF THE
WORK.
SHE'S LEGISLATIVE ADDED ADVOCATE
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS
LAURIE LEWIS AND I'M THE
EDUCATION DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL TANITH AND I
AM VERY --
MUCH ASKING FOR YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL I WORK WITH YOUTH ALL
OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT I'M
HAVING IS --
HAVING THEM FORGET WORK --
EXPERIENCE AND THE STORY THAT
I'D LIKE TO TELL US OF A
PARTICULAR YOUTH WAS A YOUNG MAN
WHO WAS TRYING --
TO HE WAS NOT ATTENDING SCHOOL
IN SCHOOL HE STARTED TO ACHIEVE
HIS GRADES BUT HE COULD NOT MAKE
IT TO A TWO POINT.
OH AND THEREFORE HE WAS DENIED
HIS WORK PERMIT HE GOT TO ONE
POINT.
NINE AND NO MATTER HOW MUCH WE
NEGOTIATED WITH THE SCHOOL NO
MATTER HOW MUCH OFFER OF EXTRA
FOR ENTERING THEY SET THEIR
HANDS WERE TIED.
SO -- IN
THIS -- AND
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS
BILL TO HELP OTHER STUDENTS LIKE
ITSELF -- TO
ACHIEVE THAT BECAUSE WE REALLY
WANT TO HELP STUDENTS GET THEIR
WORK EXPERIENCE ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE UNABLE --
TO MAINTAIN THEIR ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE IN ADDITION SAYS TO
SUPPORTING.
A THE FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES OF
LOW INCOME YOUTH IN SECURING THE
WORK PERMIT --
IN THESE SITUATIONS ALLOWING
THEM TO WORK IN A GOVERNMENT
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM --
IT ALSO HELPS LONG COMMUTE MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS RESEARCH FROM
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK WITH LOW
INCOME USED WHO DO WORK --
SHOW THAT THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
I'M INCOME IS GOING BACK INTO
THEIR HOUSEHOLD HELP PAY FOR
RENT TO HELP PAY FOR FOOD THAT
WAS CERTAINLY MY EXPERIENCE WHEN
I WORKED AS A LOW INCOME YOUTH --
AND IN THE CASE OF MY SISTER
WHEN SHE WAS UNABLE TO SECURE A
WORK PERMIT BECAUSE OF HER LOW
GRADES AND POOR ATTENDANCE SHE
DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND YOU NEVER WENT BACK THIS IS
WHAT AT THE CHILDREN THE LAURIE
IS WORKING WITH DAY IN AND DAY
OUT ARE FACING HOW WE FEEL LIKE
IF THEY ARE.
AND IF THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ATTEND A PROGRAM WHERE THEY
CAN BUILD THEIR SKILLS AND
FUTURE AND MEET THEIR CURRENT
NEEDS -- WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THEM
AND THESE ENDEAVORS AND NOT
PUNISH THEM FOR NOT BEING
SUCCESSFUL IN THE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT WE LARGER I BOTH
THINK.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ERICA OFTEN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO SEE THIS AS
A POTENTIAL STUDENT WORKS DURING
THE SUMMER THEY START LEARNING
THOSE WORK SKILLS.
THEY TAKE THOSE BACK TO SCHOOL
DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR AND
HOPEFULLY THEN WE CAN HELP TO
IMPROVE THEIR TENANTS AND
THEY'RE GREAT SO I WOULD URGE
THANK YOU --
AND THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THIS
BILL THINGS COULD BILL I'D LIKE
TO EXTEND IT YOUR LONG WILL HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION LATER.
BUT I DO SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
OF STUDENTS WORKING TO BE ABLE
TO GET WORK I'VE HAD STUDENTS
WHO WORK FULL TIME.
VIGOR WORK ALL NIGHT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY PERMITTED OR NOT
BUT THEY DID IT.
BECAUSE THEY NEEDED TO EAT AND
NOT EVERY IN THE WORLD ALSO
THANK YOU AND THE OTHERS --
WHO WISH TO COMMENT?
I IS SAYING THAT IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED.
BY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT PLEASE
CLOSE.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I GO
DOWN WITH YOU IN REGARDS EXTENT
ALL YEAR LONG FOR SOME WE HAD
TAKEN THEM TO KEEP THE BILL
MOVING ON THE OTHER SIDE
UNDERSTOOD CONSUMER.
UNDERSTOOD.
A CALL THE ROLL PLEASE AGAIN
MOTIONS TO PASS TO LABOR
EMPLOYMENT.
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I STEINORTH THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I DOES FIVE VOTED IS OUT
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU TO YOUR WITNESSES --
AND WE WE DO HAVE ONE BILL ON
CALL THAT'S FOUND MEMBER NINE
THAT'S S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HELL --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY.
SO WE'RE NOT.
GONNA FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE THAT
CENTER HILLS BILL [inaudible]
SORT OF WHAT I CAN [inaudible]
KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
IT'S GOT FOUR VOTES.
THE BILL HAS A FOR VOTE SO IT IS
OUT.
IF ANYBODY WISHES THAT ON WILL
DO THAT OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
MINUTES.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED